JENNY BROWN: Let's face it.
We've all got control issues.
They might keep us up
at night, and sometimes
they even limit our ability
to work with others.
Fortunately, Cloud Storage
Bytes is here to help.
Well, as long as your
particular control issues
revolve around dealing
with and managing
versioning in the Cloud.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Have you ever accidentally
deleted a file
that you meant to keep?
What about if someone
else deletes your stuff?
It's frustrating,
to say the least.
More importantly, imagine this
experience for your users.
Fortunately, you can
course correct and monitor
potential accidental data
removal from your Cloud Storage
bucket thanks to
object versioning.
For a quick review,
Google Cloud Storage
uses object versioning to
protect your Cloud Storage
data from being overwritten
or accidentally deleted.
Sounds great, right?
So let's get right into how
this versioning thing works.
Object versioning gets
enabled on a bucket
using gsutil or the REST API.
Once enabled, Cloud Storage
creates an archived version
of an object each time the
live version of the object
is overwritten or deleted.
That being said,
if you move a file,
it effectively
loses its history.
So for example, if I have
file cat with three versions
and I move cat to chonker,
then cat is still there
with three versions,
and now chonker
is there with one version.
But as far as Cloud
Storage can tell,
there is no connection showing
that chonker was once cat.
As for overwritten
or deleted objects,
the archived version keeps
the name of the object,
but is uniquely identified
by a generation number.
All objects have generation
numbers associated with them,
but only archived objects
require generation numbers
to identify them.
Whenever object
versioning is enabled,
you can list archived
versions of an object,
restore the live version of
an object to an older state,
or permanently delete
an archived version
as needed using gsutil
or the REST API.
You can turn versioning on or
off for a bucket at any time.
Turning off versioning
leaves existing object
versions in place,
but going forward,
the bucket stops accumulating
new archived object versions.
Cloud Storage uses two
different properties
that, together, identify
the version of an object.
One property identifies the
version of the object's data.
The other property
identifies the version
of the object's metadata.
These properties are always
present with every version
of the object, even if object
versioning is not enabled.
They can be used
as preconditions
for conditional
updates to enforce
the ordering of those updates.
Archived objects have
their own metadata,
which may differ from the
metadata of live objects.
Most importantly here
is an archived version
retains its access
control lists,
so it may not necessarily
have the same permissions
as the live version
of that same object.
Each object, whether
live or versioned,
has one set of metadata.
Only the latest metageneration
numbers refer to that metadata.
Older metageneration numbers
cannot be used to access
metadata that has
since been changed.
You can update metadata
for an archived object
by specifying its
generation in your request.
To ensure safe
read-modify-write semantics,
you can use a
metageneration-match
precondition.
Using this precondition
causes the update
to fail if the metadata
you're attempting to update
was changed between the time you
read the metadata and the time
you sent the update.
Now, all of this sounds
pretty abstract, so let's
explore an example.
Let's see what happens to
the file cat in a bucket
with object versioning enabled
as you overwrite, update, move,
and delete the file.
You start by uploading
an image called cat.
When you first upload
cat to Cloud Storage,
it receives a generation number
and a metageneration number.
In this example, the
generation number is this.
Because the object is new, the
metageneration number is 1.
Cat receives generation
and metageneration numbers
even though object
versioning is not enabled.
For instructions,
see the documentation
for viewing the object
metadata linked below.
Now, you decide to enable object
versioning for your bucket.
This doesn't affect the
generation or metageneration
numbers of cat.
But what about when you
update the metadata?
Say you update the
metadata for cat
by adding a custom metadata--
color, black.
Updating metadata causes the
metageneration value of cat
to increase, in this
case, from 1 to 2.
However, the object
itself remains unchanged.
So Cloud Storage continues to
store only one version of cat,
and the version still has
the same generation number.
Now you upload a
new version of cat
to your Cloud Storage bucket.
When you do so,
object versioning
moves the existing cat object
into an archived state.
The archived version retains the
same storage class and metadata
it previously had.
The archived version
appears only if you
perform a versioned listing.
It does not appear in the
normal listing commands.
The archived version is
now referenced like this.
Meanwhile, the
newly uploaded cat
becomes the live
version of the object.
This new cat gets its
own generation number.
It also gets its own metadata
and a metageneration number
of 1, which means
it does not contain
the color black metadata
unless you specify it.
When you access or
modify cat, this
is the version that's used.
You can alternatively refer
to this version of cat
using its generation number.
For example, when
using the gsutil tool,
you would refer to it
with this file name.
What if I decide to
move cat to chonker?
Now when I view the
archived versions,
I find that cat is
now fully archived.
The metageneration
number for chonker
is 1 even though there
were two versions of cat.
When moving an object
in Cloud Storage,
you're actually making a
copy, and then deleting
the old version.
This new object doesn't
retain the versioning data
of the old one.
OK.
You've decided you prefer
dogs, so you delete chonker.
When you do this, the version
that had this generation number
becomes archived.
Your bucket now contains
two archived version
of cat and no live versions.
You can still refer to
either archived version
by using its generation
number, but if you
try to access cat without a
generation number, it fails.
Similarly, a normal object
listing of the bucket
will not show cat as one of
the objects in the bucket.
For information on listing
archived versions of objects,
see Listing Archived Object
Versions, linked below.
You disable object
versioning, which
stops future object archiving.
Existing archived
versions of objects
remain in Cloud Storage.
And even though object
versioning is disabled,
both cat versions remain
stored in your bucket
until you delete
them, either manually
using the command at
gsutil rm or through using
Object Lifecycle Management,
which is a topic for a totally
different video.
Even with object
versioning disabled,
you can restore one of the
existing archived versions
by making a copy of it.
To do so simply named
the copy you make cat.
Once you do this, your
bucket has three versions
of cat, the two archived
versions and the one
live version that came
from making a copy.
And there you go.
You can now manage versioning
on your own Cloud buckets.
On a side note, do keep in mind
that enabling object versioning
increases storage costs.
This can be partially reduced
by configuring Object Lifecycle
Management to delete
older object versions,
but that's for another episode.
If you'd like to know more about
managing object versioning,
check out the links
in the description.
Don't forget to
subscribe, give us a Like,
and tell us what you want
to learn about Google Cloud
Storage.
Thanks for joining us on this
quick Byte of Cloud Storage.
See you next time.
[MUSIC PLAYING]